10 faut-il vendre 10 % de la SAQ et
d'Hydro Québec pour rembourser une
partie de la dette on pose la question
parce que tout se
calcule je suis franchement contre qu'on
privatise la SAQ et hydroquébec surtout
pour c'est notre vache allé c'est à nous
ça nous appartient à tout le monde à
tous les Québécois même si je suis une
émigré ça pourrait être une bonne idée
euh moi je suis pas mal à droite je
considère que tous les moyens sont bons
on peut considérer toutes sortes de
moyens comme ça pour réduire la dette du
Québec bonjour bienvenue à ce tout
nouveau rendez-vous tous les vendredis
comme ça cette heure-ci sur ici RDI tout
ce calculle parce que derrière les
chiffres il y a des enjeux qui vous
concernent combien ça vous coûte combien
ça vous rapporte quel est la stratégie
derrière une mesure annoncée par le
gouvernement c'est ça l'idée qui est
derrière tout ce calcul et puis
aujourd'hui B le gouvernement Couillard
on pose la question le gouvernement
devrait-il vendre des actifs pour
réduire sa dette l'idée circule et a été
reprise par les économistes Luc godbau
et Claude montmarket dans leur rapport
remis au gouvernement vendredi dernier
avec nous Lisa frula et en remplacement
de Rimy Trudel Pierre Paquet bonjour à
vous deux bonjour bonjour géralf c'est
un plaisir de vous retrouver dans le
cadre de cette émission tous ce calcul
on va s'intéresser particulièrement euh
justement à la vente des actifs puis je
veux vous dire qu'un peu plus tard dans
l'émission on va parler des négociations
avec les centrales saint fiscal on va
parler également on va faire des
parallèles sur les finances publiques
entre le Québec et l'Ontario l'Ontario
qui présentait un budget hier et qui ça'
va en élection le 12 juin prochain ça a
été confirmé et je vous mentionne
également que si vous avez le goût de
commenter nos sujets sur Twitter vous le
faites sans problème puis durant
l'émission on pourra voir vos
commentaires Lisa froula d'abord si ça
devait devenir nécessaire d'évaluer la
possibilité de vendre une partie
d'hydroquébec ou une partie de la SAQ
est-ce que vous pensez ce sont des
options qu'on devrait envisager moi je
suis toujours craintif là quand on parle
de vente d'actifs surtout de vente
d'actifs de notre vachealis alors s'il
faut le faire je dis bien si majuscule
après une grande discussion avec
l'ensemble des Québécois s'il faut le
faire alors à ce moment-là il va falloir
le faire il va falloir le faire mais
considérer aussi les risques c'est sûr
que les avantages c'est que l'argent que
l'on reçoit par exemple de 10 % on le
met à la dette et on ne pe plus les
intérêts de la dette parce qu'on l'
diminue ou premier avantage mais le
désavantage c'est que là il faut
absolument s'assurer que les tarifs
d'électricité sont à son maximum pour
que la société puisse donner de le plus
de dividendes poss possible alors ça il
faut mettre tout ça sur la table mais
moi je vous dis tout de suite la vente
d'actif là de ces que ça soit
hydroquébec que ce soit l'autoquébec que
ce soit la
SAQ si c'est sur la table mettons que
c'est sur la table Pierre Paquet est-ce
qu'on regarde la possibilité mais sans
nécessairement arriver à la conclus
conclusion qu'il faut vendre mais est-ce
qu'on devrait explorer ça moi je trouve
pas ça intéressant du tout on parle
d'une valeur d'à peu près 50 milliards
de dollars pour hydro et pour la SAQ
donc si on enant 10 % c'est une rentrée
de 5 milliards de dollars la dette est à
peu près actuellement à
160 182 milliards la dette net alors on
tomberait à quoi à 175 pu on se
priverait à ce moment-là d'à peu près
300 20 millions de dividendes qui
viennent de l'UTO Québec et pas de l'UTO
Québec c'estàd de la SAQ et au Québec
pour le reste des de la période alors
moi je pense pas que ce soit une une
voie à suivre pour régler de façon
structurelle le problème des finances
publiques du Québec je vous écoute mais
Luc godbou et Claude montmarquet disent
attention il faut trouver des revenus il
faut euh réduire les dépenses bien les
contrôler ces dépenseslà et si on
narrive pas à contrôler les dépenses ben
il va falloir trouver d'autres solutions
des solution pas à contrôler les
dépenses alors retournons-nous et
première ch il y a des choses à faire
avant c'est de regarder l'ensemble des
dépenses deuxièmement on parlait de la
révision de programme ensuite on va
parler tantôt de de des ententes avec
les syndicats après ça il faut parler
aussi peut-être du fonctionnement des
trou Québec ça c'est autre chose mais de
de commencer à dire parce qu'une fois
que l'actif est vendu tu peux plus aller
ou une partie on parle de 10 % mais
difficile après ça d'aller le racheter
encore une fois on parle de 5 milliards
de dollars alors c'est pas c'est pas et
ça va avoir des conséquences sur la
gouvernance de ces ces et puis m Pr la
SQ estce qu'on va des succursales quel
succursal le secteur privé va vouloir
acheter celles qui sont rentables les
plus rentables donc on va se retrouver
avec une société d'État partiellement
privatisé qui va qui va avoir moins être
moins performant qu'elle l' présentement
alors moi je vois vraiment pas
d'avantage de ce côté c'est les
économistes godbou et mon Market qui ont
ramené le
sujet à l'ordre du jour parce que en
2007 Claude Garcia et Marcel Boyer
avaient fait une étude c'est cette
étude-ci 130 milliards disait-on
l'évaluation desdrog Québec en 2009
monsieur Garcia a réévalué à 53
milliards et là aujourd'hui ilvant à
l'air 2014 dit quand on regarde ne9u
fois les les bénéfices on est autour de
75 milliards à Québec on va retrouver
d'ailleurs l'auteur l'auteur de l'étude
de 2007 et de l'étude de 2009 Claude
Garcia qui est dans nos studios
administrateur de société bonsoir
Monsieur Garcia bonsoir Monsieur Filion
est-ce que vous êtes toujours favorable
on est parce que je parle d'étude de
2007- 200009 on est en 2014 est-ce que
vous êtes toujours favorable à l'idée de
privatiser une partie d'hydroquébec oui
euh oui parce que je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi c'est que dans mon étude de
2009 là parce que en 2009 j'avais changé
un peu la façon de le faire euh je
j'arrivais à une des conclusions auquell
j'arrivais c'est que il y avait 2
milliards de profits à aller chercher
sans toucher au tarif et hydroquébec a
fait un certains progrès à ce niveau-là
mais je suis convaincu qu'il reste plus
qu'un milliard et demi entre 1 milliard
et demi 1 milliard et 3/4 de profit
aller chercher sans augmenter les tarifs
donc c'est clair que si on faisait une
privatisation partielle comme leur
proposent les deux économistes et qu'on
faisait en même temps un certain nombre
de changements la gouvernance
d'hydroquébec on pourrait augmenter
beaucoup la valeur de l'entreprise
puisqu'on pourrait augmenter les les
bénéfices de l'entreprise et on vendrait
ça combien euh écoutez ça je pense que
ça dépend comment on va le faire mais
regardez moi ce que je propose c'est
ceci c'est que on peut pas vendre hydro
au Québec sans faire aucun changement de
gouvernance c'est à mon avis ça serait
dilapider le plus importants actifs don
dispose la société québécoise faut quand
même pas se leurer euh et moi ça me ça
me chagrine beaucoup de voir comment les
gouvernements ont mal géré HD Québec
depuis 50 ans euh parce que on a au
Québec on dispose d'une richesse
extraordinaire de l'eau et ça coûte
absolument rien une fois que les
barrages sont faits pour produire
deélectricité ça coûte rien de de de
d'intat les intrats sont gratuits je ve
juste bien comprendre quand vous parlez
de d'améliorer la gouvernance améliorer
la gouvernance à avant de vendre une
partie d'hydroquébec oui oui absolument
parce que vend combien d'hydrookébec 10
% ah ben on peut commencer avec 10 mais
moi ce que je propose les changements
que je propose ce sont les suivants
première chose à faire c'est que le
dividende actuel j'en fais une redevance
donc le 2 milliards que le gouvernement
va chercher ça deviendrait une redevance
comme j'ai proposé dans mon étude de
2009 ensuite toute la hausse de tarif du
bloc patrimonial ça serait également au
moins 90 % des bénéfice de ça ça se
traduirait par une hausse de rdevance
parce que vendre hydroquébec au tarif
actuel d'électricité c'est transférer la
valeur extraordinaire du bloc
patrimonial au secteur privé et ça c'est
pas une bonne idée je pense que on doit
plutôt le faire sous forme de redevance
et c'est redevance vont se répéter dans
l'avenir ok monsieur Garcia je juste
donner la parole à Lisa frou et Pierre
Paquet là-dessus qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez je me demande si quand on parle
de la vente d'Hydro Québec est-ce que
toujours la vente partielle ou mais
est-ce que le raisonnement c'est que
forcément avec une partie du privé on va
rendre ido Québec plus efficace efficace
pour tout le monde est-ce que ça devient
un moyen cette venteel tout en
bénéficiant évidemment des rentrées
d'argent là pour diminuer la dette mais
est-ce que c'est ça le raisonnement
paquet d'abord le le problème c'est qu'à
ce moment-là hydroquébec devra tenir
compte des des des intérêts de ces
actionnaires privés là ça sera plus une
société d'État il y aura une pression
moi à mon avis si on veut faire un débat
sur la gestion de d'hydroquébec on peut
le faire dans le cadre d'un d'une
société d'État euh des gens proposent et
pu je pense que ça ça ça serait beaucoup
plus intéressant à regarder au lieu de
tarifer au coout moyen comme c'est le
cas présentement qu'on le tarif que les
tarif soit basé sur le coût marginal
alors ça ça revenus c'estàdire sur les
derniers investissements qui sont qui
ont été faits les derniers barrages ont
coûté plus cher que les premers ça
monter tarifs mais euh sauf que ça
permettrait au gouvernement du Québec
d'avoir des des dividendes plus
importants alors c'est un débat moi que
je trouve plus intéressant à faire que
la privatisation de de cette société
d'Ét et Monsieur Garcia je veux juste
vous soumettre les les chiffres de Ivan
aler que vous connaissez qui dit écoutez
si on devait vendre 10 % de la SAQ et
d'Hydro Québec on aurait à peu près 5
milliards pour les deux et on perdrait à
peu près 300 millions en revenus 300
millions de revenus annuels c'est 6 % du
5 milliards il ont pas prêter sur le
marché à 3,5 % oui mais c'est pour ça
monsieur filon que je propose des
changements à la gouvernance parce que
privatiser Hydro Québec même à 10 % je
je le répète et Monsieur pquet le passe
à côté du sujet en suggérant d'augmenter
les tarif moi je parle pas d'augmenter
les tarif on peut aller chercher 1
milliard et demi à 2 milliards de profit
additionnel sans toucher prof au au
tarif simplement rendantroquébec aussi
efficace que la moyenne des entreprises
privées auquelles
je êche de faire dans leadre Public je
vraiment pas pourquoi il faut envisager
la privatisation mais c'était ça ma
question monsieur garç il a jamais une
entreprise publ qui a été d'État qui été
aussi efficac les meilleures entreprises
privées j'en connais pas monsieur
parquet et je pense au Québec ou hyro a
fait des efforts mais les efforts sont
insuffisants et ça va prendre énormément
de temps au rythme
actuel juste une chose c'est ça ma
question c'est que est-ce que pour vous
cette privatisation là partiel toujours
au lieu de donner du en plus de donner
des des des revenus du du capital à
mettre contre la dette ça ça assure une
une bonne gouvernance est-ce que je vous
suis bien dans votre raisonnement oui
c'est exactement j'ai pas eu le temps de
finir tout à l'heure parce que mais une
des une autre chose je pense et il faut
suivre à ce moment-là les modèles qu'on
a utilisé en Europe où on a privatisé
partiellement dans un premier temps et
on a gardé l'État a gardé ce qu'on a
appelé une une action en
ou golden shares si vous me permettez la
langue de Shakespeare et en vertu de ce
golden shares là l'état gardait des des
droits ça prait l'accord de l'État pour
des transactions des achats des ventes
d'actifs et ça prenait également
l'accord de l'État pour émettre des
actions additionnelles mais c'est une
façon
de de et mais par contre on donnait le
contrôle des opérations quotidiennes aux
actionnaires privés et en passant ces
actionnaires privés là ça peut très bien
parti la Caisse de dépôt qui
effectivement gère les épangles de tous
les Québécois alors Monsieur monsieur
Garcia merci beaucoup pour cette
approche parce que je sais que vous avez
beaucoup pensé à ça puis beaucoup écrit
dans les dernières années cet apport est
important merci beaucoup monsieur Garcia
merci monsieur F merci beaucoup au
revoir et je veux simplement vous
montrer la valeur parce qu'on a abordé
rapidement là les dividendes ce que
rapporte hydroquébec et ce que rapporte
la Société des alcools du Québec au
gouvernement alors le dividende pour le
gouvernement 2014-25 2 milliards 900
millions pour Hydro Québec et la SAQ
rapporte 1 milliard donc c'est un total
de 3 milliard900 millions c'est pas les
revenus ça parce que les revenus sont
plus élevés que ça c'est le dividende
qui est versé au gouvernement du Québec
alors voilà pour cette parti pr de 400
millions par année de moi c'est parce
que ce qui me surprend moi je comprends
le raisonnement de Monsieur garçon mais
d'un autre côté je me dis est-ce
possible d'avoir une bonne gouvernance
et de se poser les vraies questions
aujourd'hui en 2014 sans se départir de
nos actifs bon voilà alors la question
est encore ouverte on a parlé un peu
merci beaucoup on va parler on va
poursuivre la discussion dans un instant
parce que vous savez quand on se regarde
on se désole mais quand on se compare on
se console c'est pas moi qui l' inventé
celle-là et on peut se demander si c'est
la question qu'on peut se poser aussi
dans le cas de la dette publique est-ce
par exemple est-ce que c'est mieux en
Ontario qui s'en va en élection
d'ailleurs on va en discuter après la
pause en plus des négociations à venir
entre le Québec et les syndicats mais
d'abord que pensez-vous vous de cette
idée de privatisation
faudrait qu'on utilise mieux en fait la
ressource duid Québec je pense queid
Québec peut nous
fournir beaucoup d'argent c'est un peu
on entend souvent dire que c'est la
vache alla du Québec je pense que s'il y
Ava une partie qui serait au privé
probablement qui serait plus rentable
parce que un investisseur privé va
s'arranger pour que ça ça lui rapporte
je suis complètement contre je pense
qu'on a aucune étude aucune preuve que
le secteur privé plus performant que le
secteur public privé de
pourét observe et analyser chaque jour
la politique et ses acteurs c'est vous
donner le pouvoir de comprendre et
d'agir sur les enjeux qui vous
touchent ici
RDI quand le monde politique semble
déconnecté fait un devoir deuser les
enjeux et je reçois les grands acteurs
pour aller avec eux au fond des sujets
ont un impact sur votre vie LESISS du
pouvoir
dimanche3 RDI Gill Vig les beau
jours qui d'amour et d'au
frache pass la façon des flèches
disponible
maintenantour voici le confort du cuir
Napa voici un intérieur tout équipé avec
soin voici un toit ouvrant à double
panneau voici ce qui vous garde connecté
sur le monde voici vitess vous donne 6,4
l au 100 km sur route et des feux d'il
de série voici la liberté d'explorer
autant de nouveaux horizons que vous le
désirer le tout nouveau Jeep
Cherokee après avoir financé les études
de leurs deux enfants et réduit leur
hypothèque Susanne et Luc ont constaté
qu'il leur restait à peine assez
d'argent pour régler les facture
mensuelle puis ils ont entendu parler du
programme de revenu résidentiel CHIP
grâce au programme de revenus
résidentiel chip ils ont pu avoir accès
à une partie de la valeur de leur
propriété sous forme d'un montant non
imposable ils ont choisi une somme
initiale de 200000 dollars pour leur
dett et des versements mensuels de 2000
dollars le stress a disparu et la vie
est belle si vous avez plus de 55 ans
vous pouvez recevoir jusqu'à 50 % de la
valeur de votre propriété sous forme de
montant non imposable grâce au programme
chip offert par la banque home equity
vous n'avez pas à faire de paiement
jusqu'à ce que vous décidiez de
déménager ou de vendre et vous restez
propriétaire de votre maison et en
garder le contrôle et grâce à nos
faibles taux il n'y a jamais eu de
meilleur moment pour profiter du
programme de revenus résidentiel CHIP de
la banque homeity pour obtenir votre
guide gratuit faites le 1866 482 2447 ou
visiteer
hypothécairechip.ca pe-être comme un
implant dans main tu parles en POM tu
Tex ave tes doigts puis puis là je
raccroche ouais des hologrames qui flent
audessus de l'écran projeter grandeur
nature devant toi dans mon oreille VO me
dit VO aller magasiner pour les souliers
en sol de tourner à gauche une casquette
téléphone he quoi je fais juste un appel
peu importe que l'avenir nous réserve il
y a Rogers Express abonnez-vous
maintenant et obtenez le plus récent
téléphone intelligent chaque année un
autre avantage fleximax de Rogers
bienvenue au supermarché de
Julie allez venez faites comme chez vous
quand vous adhérez au programme de
récompense PRC plus c'est comme si vous
étiez dans votre magasin personnalisé
vous pouvez accumuler des points
rapidement sur les produits que vous
achetez souvent et avec notre
application plus besoin de cœurir les ob
inscrivez-vous au programme de
récompense PC plus c'est facile et
gratuit et en plus on vous donne votre
carte en
magasin Gilles
Vigon
vivre vivre debout disponible
maintenantsur
vire on parle finan publiqu à tous ce
calcul avec Lisa frulat Pierre Paquette
également et c'est intéressant de parler
de finances publiques de budget monsieur
l'tao prépare son budget pour quelque
part dans les deux premières semaines de
juin hier l'Ontario présentait son
budget budget qui ne sera jamais déposé
et qui ne sera pas défait euh les
conservateurs le NPD ont déjà dit qu'ils
étaient pas d'accord avec le budget qui
allez pas l'appuyer madame wen a annoncé
des élections en Ontario pour le 12 juin
et là je pose la question puisqu'on
parle d' l'Ontario des finance publique
qu'Ant en élection et qu'on parle du
budget du Québec est-ce qu'on dramatise
la situation du Québec quand on se
compare on se console diront certains
voici les chiffres de comparaison sur le
déficit et la dette entre le Québec et
l'Ontario l'Ontario déficit 2014 2015 12
milliards et demi au Québec 1illard 750
millions c'est ce qui est visé et quand
quand on regarde la dette par rapport au
PIB la dette nette 38,9 % en Ontario
49,8 % au Québec donc on voit que c'est
plus lourd l'endettement au Québec par
rapport au PIB mais le déficit est
largement plus bas que celui de
l'Ontario Pierre Paquet là-dessus est-ce
qu'on dramatise la situation des
finances public moi je pense on la
dramatise effectivement et pu ça empêche
un débat je dirais serein sur la
question parce que c'est évident que il
y a quand même un problème de revenus on
le voit d'ailleurs actuellement c'est
pas tant les dépenses qui son contrôle
c'est les revenus qui rentrent pas parce
que on est dans une situation bon
évidemment on est sorti de la récession
puis la reprise est fragile
particulièrement aux États-Unis et comme
on exporte beaucoup aux États-Unis ça
affecte beaucoup nos entreprises puis
l'ensemble de l'activité économique et
l'autre chose c'est qu' il y a pas
d'inflation normalement les ministre des
Finances
pouvaent pouvait profiter s'appuyer sur
une inflation qui était quand même assez
intéressante donc les revenusroiss Natur
naturelle des revenus là il y a pas
d'inflation et ça pose un problème ceci
dit je rappelle que de depuis 96 depuis
Lucien Bouchard il y a eu beaucoup de
travail qui s'est fait pour contrôler
nons améliorer les finances publiques et
ça ça apparu d'ailleurs dans le
pourcentage de la dette par rapport au
PIB aussi bien brut que que net et quand
on regarde de 98 à 2008 avant la
récession il s'est fait au au net un
surplu de 2 milliards de dollars quand
on regarde les déficits et puis plus
avant la crise donc ça veut dire que on
était sur la bonne voie maintenant comme
tout le monde on su la crise ise on a eu
des déficites dans les dernières années
on a le vieillissement de la population
est-ce qu'on a raison d'être alarmé ça
faut faire attention à être alarmé je
pense que de regarder la situation de
façon responsable et sérieuse et que ce
soit le gouvernement précédent ou le
gouvernement actuel les deux
gouvernements ont regardé ça puis on dit
écoutez là on a pas le choix un faut les
contrôler nos dépenses puis deuxièmement
compte tenu justement de la démographie
du vieillissement de la population
sachant que dans 30 ans en 2030 pas dans
30 ans mais dans 2030 il y aura 2.1 pour
de travailleurs pour un retraité de 65
ans et plus alors que dans les années
70i 70 c'était à peu près 7.2 % de
travailleurs pour un une personne à la
retraite de 65 et plus alors il y a tout
ça qu'il faut tenir ça
en là non plus faut pas dramatiser parce
que dans les années 60 on avait beaucoup
de jeunes à l'école et puis les actifs
payai pour les les jeunes quii mais sais
au moins
on
éit ai années0 alors que ça fair venir
c'est S mais faut pas non plus
dramatiser actuellement il y a se
provinces sur 10 qui sont en déficit et
celle qui est la moins en déficit des
SEP c'est le Québec alors il faut quand
même relativiser les choses conjoncturel
en grand oui mais pi sauf que le rapport
de notre dette par rapport au PB c'est
la plus élevée au Canada oui d'accord
mais tendance à diminuer depuis 96 8 DEP
9 ou oui il faut continuer à l'êre mais
il faut pas non plus cou je
mon vous avez raison de parler la dette
je veux juste vous montrer ça va ça va
ajouter regardez en 2004 2005 l'intérêt
sur la dett c'était 7 milillliards 4 7
milliard 8 5 ans plus tard et
aujourd'hui 11 milliards ça c'est ce que
nous coûte notre dette à chaque année
c'est encore faut faut le mettre en
proportion du PIB pour pour voir
vraiment le poids que ça représente ou
encore en proportion des recettes de
l'État ou des dépenses de l'État je dis
pas que c'est euh que c'est pas
important parce qu'effectivement quand
on rembourse les frais sur la dette ça
ne va pas à la santé ça va pas à
l'éducation aux infrastructures
routières mais il faudrait regarder les
chiffres notre dette S lourdit et les
investir dans les infrastructures c'est
emprinter sur le marché c'est alourdir
la dette le gouvernement veut investir
davantage dans infr en Ontario c'est en
Ontario ils ont annoncé un programme
hier jeécoutais là 29 milliards sur 10
ans et ça c'est tout enfit
l'infrastructure routièrees les hôpitaux
les écoles
mais en plus parce que quand même pas
oublier qu'en 2009 l'Ontario a été
frappé de front à cause de tout l' son
industrie manufacturière c'est de la
grosse la criserie manufacturière et son
industrie automobile alors elle le S
fond alors ils ont tout arrêté
évidemment les dépenses ils étaient
obligés mais ils ont dit hier la
première chose qu' a dit le ministre des
Finances de l'Ontario Jobs jobs and jobs
alors oui ils investissent d'un côté
coûte que coûte on va voir par exemple
génér c'est là où les décisions que les
libéraux vont avir à prendre vont être
intéressant à par exemple ils avaient
augmenté de beaucoup les les annonces
pour les infrastructures je pense de 90
milliards à 150 milliards sur 10 ans
mais ça c'est de la dette de plus mais
est-ce que c'est de la bonne dette comme
on dit mais c'est de la dette de plus
pare pas le choix c'est ça fait que il
faut faut regarder je dirais ces
dépenses d'infrastructure là en
proportion de la croissance économique
qu'on va connaître on sera pas toujours
à à 1 % là il y aura sûrement au cours
des prochaines années une augmentation
de la croissance et d'ailleurs c'est
juste une petite remarque que je voulais
faire pour les l'étude de de montmarket
et godbou ils annoncent une croissance
supérieure à ce que Monsieur Marceau
annoncait dans son budget mais sans
effet sur les revenus al ça c'est un
petit peu ça m un petit peu intrigué
alors une des options bien sûr c'est de
réviser les programmes c'est de
renégocier aussi avec les syndicats
c'est de voir le travail qui peut être
fait et Monsieur Couillard a été très
clair les les les premières heures les
premiers jours quand il s'est prononcé
sur les mesures d'austérité entre
guillemets je parle pas de politique
d'austérité mais vraiment de certaines
mesures d'austérité qui peuvent être
adoptés ça inquiétait beaucoup les
syndicats les les les syndicats ont
rencontré Monsieur Couillard hier puis
on a eu l'impression qu'ils étaient un
peu rassurés on les
écoute je pense que ce qui est également
important de mentionner c'est que
Monsieur Couillard nous a aussi dit que
la situation des finances publiques
était préoccupante mais c'était pas
catastrophique mais c'est-à-dire quand
on regarde la question des finances
publiques faut être capable de la
regarder de façon globale il nous a
annoncé qu'il y aurait un débat une
genre de commission sur les finances
publiques sur le financement ça pour
nous c'est une ouverture qui est
intéressante ah ben là c'est intéressant
est-ce que le Bonon est au rendez-vous
pour la suite des choses contrairement à
1982 contrairement à 2003 est-ce que là
le Bonton est au rendez-vous moi je vais
vous dire celui qui moi me fait penser
là Philippe Couillard ma fait penser à
mon ancien patron qui est Monsieur
borassa il ferait vraiment penser puis
un mélange de Monsieur borassa et de
Lucien Bouchard Lucien Bouchard avait
réussi à réunir autour de la table j'y
étais tu y étais dans le grand sommet de
Montréal cette cette cette cette
préoccupation sur la dette les finances
publiques ils avaient embarqué aussi les
les
syndicats les groupes communautaires
étaient présent et justement parce que
là il y avait les chiffres on a pu
discuter des chiffres s'entendre sur un
certain nombre de chos et un échéancier
pour arriver à l'équilibre budgétaire
moi je pense que c'est pas le prochain
budget ou le budget qui vont qui va
suivre qui va être le problème les les
les les agences de notation ils savent
très bien ce qu'ils veulent avoir c'est
un plan
de stabilisation des finances publiques
sur le long terme et donc je pense que
ça va prendre la discussion du dialogue
socialou qui Rapp de 1982 1982 c'était
20 % de réduction d'un cout en 1982
monsieur Pariso pour les plus haut
salariés et puis ça duré 3 mois mais ça
a fait très mala psychologiquement
particulièrement aux enseignants je peux
vous en parler il m'en parle encore
aujourd'hui et 2003 aussi pu il y avait
eu des manifestations voit les images en
1982 et en 2003 aussi quand monsieur
char est arrivé qu'il a parlé de
réingénierie on s'est retrouvé avec des
barricades pendant plusieurs mois en
1985 quand monsieur Bourassa est arrivé
avec le rapport fortiser gobil et puis
je trois sages ça a été la même chose ça
a duré un an et après monsieur Bourassa
est revenu plus plus pragmatique alors
je suis content de voir le ton que
Monsieur Couillard prend parce que les
négociations sont en cours là le chi au
plan du secteur public il ont pas encore
déterminé euh leurs objectifs chiffrés
de de de négociation donc c'est c'est le
bon temps d'assir tout le mond en c'est
la responsabilité de tout le monde la
population elle est prêt quand on a
parlé de réingénierie on se rappelle
justement la réaction de tout le monde
aujourd'hui je je pense que
psychologiquement on est tous prêt on
est conscient il y a eu encore beaucoup
de pédagogie qui a été fait comme on
fait autour des budgets pour cours des
finances publiques maintenant les
syndicats doivent être être partie
prenant parce que 66 % du budget de
l'État c'est c'est c'est la main d'œuvre
là il a un problème aussi de de long
terme c'estàdire que devant une pénuriie
de main d'œuvre à venir i ou les
salaires sont en retard de 8% dans le
secteur public par rapport au secteur
privé alors donc il y alors nous allons
en reparler oui merci merci beaucoup si
on veut recruter il faudra payer oui
merci Pierre Paquet merci beaucoup on va
vous retrouver d'ailleurs vendredi
prochain Lisa également merci bien si
vous avez des commentaires à la maison
vous avez pu le faire par Twitter mais
vous pouvez nous écrire également à
notre adresse courriel calcul à
commercial
radiocanada.ca prochain rendez-vous
vendredi prochain même heure même poste
bien sûr à l'antenne d'ici RDI moi je
vais vous retrouver un peu plus tard à
18h30 heure de l'Est à RDI Économie nous
allons notamment vous présenter les
conseils de notre mentor de la semaine
Daniel enkel et dans un instant c'est le
Téléjournal 17h à plus
tard